les détails d'une approche comment ça il
y en a pas vous avez fait quoi je
m'embarque on pensait vraiment ensemble
c'est tout c'est parce que c'était naze
que tu ne racontes afin de rappeler j'ai
dû cette fois au
moins il monte entre eux et qui
l'enfance c'est sympa c'est l'âge où
vous en sortez j'espère c'est l'âge où
on n'est pas encore assez mûr n'a pas
encore assez forts ce déjeuner
et par les critiques il cherche une
dernière fois a été chaude le
nom mais après moi je m'en fous tu vas
tu vas lui et le truc c'est que tu es
venu chez moi plusieurs fois dormir à
poil dans mon lit tu vois là c'est un
peu plus dur j'en peux dire je suis pas
lesbienne pour que le distinguer du
temps que comme quoi
bien
mais ravi avons rencontré main c'est
très gentil de l'aider à préparer ce
genre de philosophie mais si tu es jeune
policier
je l'écoutais les ont détruits ou si
j'avais on sait jusqu'où savait qu'on
attends tu me prends pour une conne je
te comprends pour une golf jamais parce
qu'on dégage